here's let me go off on this just a
little bit to state you know how do you
live your life in the light of a
universe that is strange and that well
you can just believe anything anybody
tells you in which place you know
fetal removal by extraterrestrial
divides with your attention as you speak
Elvis in the aisles of the local
supermarket as you worry about the fall
of Atlantis and so forth and so on but
over time there has been something
evolved called the rules of evidence
colloquium known as how to tell system
shinola and the first thing is there
should be any an economy of explanation
this is called Occam's razor
in other words hypotheses should be no
more complex than is necessary to
explain whatever it is you're trying to
explain so if inability to tell dreams
from memories explains abduction why do
we have to reach for the ideas that
geneticists some of the naviga newbie
are moving secretly among us with a
surgical agenda and also carry out
unscheduled Crocket illogical
examinations and in the middle of the
night I mean really
and what I want to say about that is I
got where I am whether it is enviable or
not but I got where I am by being tough
not by being gullible and so I rejected
that amount of thing not only nubia
things but I probably tossed a few
babies out with the bathwater as well
but ask tough questions make it make
sense
and be as they say in Hawaii be Akamai
be smart understands the subtleties of
the potential degradation of language
and then trust only yourself trust only
yourself photographs are useless
anecdotes are useless what happened to
your best friend last weekend when you
weren't there is useless you can
entertain all that information but what
you have to be given the slipperiness of
language given the limitations of the
human organism you have to stay with
primary experience
and extrapolate out from there and if
you have had fetal tissues we know then
you have to deal with it but the
testimony of 700 people you don't know
that we have to bother you at all